sable
désert
van où nous sommes dans le pays des
pharaons
les pharaons hommes et femmes nés du
berceau de la civilisation que les
foules vénère comme des dieux vivants
souverain d'un peuple dont la créativité
la spiritualité et l'intelligence réunis
forment l'une des plus grandes cultures
que le monde ait jamais connu
[Musique]
à travers trois millénaires de règne sur
l'ancienne egypte il dresse à leur
propre gloire comme à celle de leur dieu
les monuments les plus imposants qui
soit les pyramides de gizeh le grand
sphinx les temples d'abidos la vallée
des rois
leurs noms majestueux ramsès cléopâtre
kheops toutankhamon évoque autant de
légendes de puissance de richesse de
conquête et de scandales
[Musique]
l'avis de certains d'entre eux est
toujours baigné de mystère
leur noble tombe en ferme
d'incomparables trésor
leur palais ont traversé les millénaires
comme le témoignage vivant du génie de
leurs architectes artistes et autres
érudits
nous vous invitons à découvrir comment
telle pharao présumé payen mènera son
pays au bord du chaos
pourquoi l'on surnomme telle autre le
napoléon de l'ancienne egypte et comment
un enfant de 6 ans devient à son tour le
personnage le plus puissant de sa
civilisation
les pharaons deux yeux de pierre fixant
l'éternité
et pour qu'ils s'y arrête un instant le
sentiment profond de visages figés dans
la passation d'un puissante héritage
enveloppé de l'ain leurs corps ont
traversé les siècles pour notre plus
grande fascination tandis que
d'innombrables sculptures peintures et
hiéroglyphes dévoile quelques aspects de
leur personnalité
[Musique]
au delà de leur rende aux dignitaires
il tisse le lien entre mortels et divin
leurs réalisations toujours grandiose
continue d'inspirer respect et
admiration des monuments demeurant comme
autant d'empreintes digitales des dieux
en personne nous vous invitons à percer
les secrets de cette ancienne lignée de
miroirs mi dieu au nom tout aussi
retentissant que par le passé voici donc
les plus grands pharaons
[Musique]
moody's est le secret de ces courants
ruban obscures en plein soleil fleuve
nourricier du peuple égyptien
[Musique]
bien avant qu un pharaon donne naissance
à une civilisation en posant sur ses
rives brune les premières pierres de
monuments extraordinaire le nil coulait
déjà paisiblement
il est à l'époque source de vie pour les
peuplades de vagabond qui ont choisi de
s'établir sur ses terres fertiles
on y trouve en abondance poissons
oiseaux ainsi que le gros gibier que
sont les crocodiles et autres
hippopotames à chaque printemps le
fleuve sort de son lit pour déposer
alentours sa couche de louvion sombre et
riche notamment en or ge sauvage c'est
essentiellement à l'aide de pierres et
filet et de pointes de flèches que la
populations préhistoriques des bords du
nil exploite ce don de la nature la vie
tout entière dépend du fleuve au point
que l'historien grec hérodote écrira
plus tard de l'egypte quel est le cadeau
du nil et le temple du monde
gravé sa marque sur les rochers des
falaises ou des déserts de la vallée du
nil
c'est l'assurance de l'offrir à la
postérité
c'est ainsi que 3000 ans avant
jésus-christ apparaissent sur ses terres
les figures principales de l'ancienne
civilisation égyptienne
les pharaons
[Musique]
les terres qui bordent le nil se
divisent naturellement deux régions
distinctes le segment le plus étroit de
la vallée qui s'étend en direction du
nord du continent africain s'appelle la
haute egypte alors que la région
luxuriante du delta du nil dont les
multiples bras se jette dans la
méditerranée se nomme la basse egypte
toutes deux formes le pays d'égypte que
nous connaissons
protégé par les déserts qui lancèrent la
vallée hautes et étroites du nil avec
ses monuments
la trace de ces inscriptions et le
développement d'une religion et d'une
philosophie mystique est la terre des
pharaons
le mot pharaons signifie simplement
belle et grande maison
les pharaons ont pour mission d' imposer
leur suprématie spirituel et politique
sur tout être vivant sous leur autorité
le symbole le plus éminent de leur
royauté et la couronne tandis que la
couronne blanche fines et longues coin
faut boire on dit confère à son porteur
le titre de souverain de haute-egypte la
couronne rouge reste l'apanage du chef
de bars egypte
seul le pharaon de toute l'egypte a le
privilège de porter les deux couronnes à
la fois
deux accessoires d'apparat accompagne
les pharaons la houlette et le fléau
on pense que la houle est
vraisemblablement en forme de bâton de
berger symbolise le guide du peuple
quant au fléau il représente à la fois
une armée l'outil servant à battre le
blé
croisés sur la poitrine du pharaon tous
deux annoncent l'homme habilité à
gouverner à protéger et à subvenir aux
besoins de son peuple dans l'egypte
ancienne
les dieux régis pratiquement tous les
aspects de la vie ils sont souvent
représentés par un animal à l'image de
la crainte mêlée d'admiration avec
laquelle les habitants d'une île
considère les bêtes partageant leur
espace vital
mais si l'on attribue aux pharaons au
pouvoir la carnation d'horus le dieu
soleil à tête de faucon la vie terrestre
ainsi que l'ordre de l'univers relève
d'une force appelé malte
[Musique]
on pourrait dire que la tâche du pharaon
consistait à faire en sorte que tous
s'accordent avec le match à défaut de
quoi l'univers organisés tels qu'ils le
connaissaient risque d'imploser en un
chaos aussi bien terrestres que cosmique
le rôle du pharaon consistait donc à
coordonner les efforts divin et humains
afin de rester en phase avec le match il
avait une fonction très importante celle
de contribuer à préserver l'univers le
début de la civilisation égyptienne
remonte à 3150 avant jésus-christ avec
l'unification des hautes et basses
egypte sous l'égide darrois guerrier peu
après sa conquête de l'ennemi sur les
terres fertiles de paepe arias
[Musique]
on doit cette découverte est une
splendide palette de schiste verts
français mis à jour lors de fouilles
entreprises aillent et raconte police
alors capitale de la haute egypte sur la
rive ouest du nil
connu sous le nom de palettes de narmer
cette plaque gravée en 3000 avant
jésus-christ constitue à ce jour le plus
vieux documents historiques sur l'egypte
voici une copie de la palette de narp
mer à peu près au tiers de sa taille
réelle
le plus grands personnages figurant sur
cette palette et le roi lui même
vous le voyez ici revêtu d'un kilt orné
d'une que deux taureaux accessoires
caractéristiques des pharaons
il est coiffé d'une couronne blanche
propre à la région de haute egypte il
brandit une massue ici pour frapper
l'ennemi étrangers l'interprétation de
cette plaque a permis d'établir que le
pharaon nar mère était le roy
responsable de l'unification du pays
ce que je tiens là et par conséquent un
document essentiel ce pharaon doit son
nom aux hiéroglyphes attenant à sa
représentation un burin surmonté d'un
poisson chat donnant le mot narmer et
pour traduction littérale poissons chats
en colère c'est vrai que ça peut nous
paraître plutôt drôle mais il faut
savoir que le nil renferme plusieurs
espèces de poissons chats électrique
capable d'infliger des décharges très
douloureuse et je pense que ce nom-là
prend là tout son sens
[Applaudissements]
la légende veut qu après avoir livré
bataille le roi est brûlé le village et
demi et tué chacun de ses soldats
c'est ce que nous révèle la scène
sculptés au dos de cette palette de
d'armes heures
face aux rois et aux disciples d'horus
figurent les restes d'un champ de
bataille avec des rangées d'individus
décapiter leur tête entre les jambes
[Musique]
ainsi il y a cinq mille ans narmer est à
l'origine d'une lignée qui marque
l'essor de la première dynastie de
pharaon
sur près de 3000 ans 29 de ces dynasties
et autres lignées familiales suivront
marquées par autant de changements de
cap dû à une absence d'héritiers ou bien
aux aléas politiques et guerrier
il
il est probable qu afin d'asseoir sa
conquête le pharaon narmer est épousé
une princesse originaire du nord
il remonte alors le nil pour fonder son
lieu de résidence sur un site connu sous
le nom de murs blancs en 3050 avant
jésus-christ au même endroit son fils
lui succède celui ci dont le nom
retrouvé sur un simple tessons de
poterie signifie faucon qui combat et le
pharaon
or à
[Musique]
il est probable corps aaa est hérité
d'un système dans lequel la plupart des
principes de la royauté égyptienne était
déjà bien ancrée après lui la position
de roi est devenue plus importante
ainsi la plus grande réalisation d'or à
reste la fondation de la ville de
memphis sur l'ancien lieu de résidence
de son père cette ville va s'étendre et
devenir la capitale politique et
religieuse de l'egypte ancienne
construite à partir de boue et de bois
elle na li s'est que très peu de
vestiges
l'historien manettes on nous révèle au
3e siècle avant jésus-christ sa
perception de cette ville au mur plan
[Musique]
man fils de loin la plus grande ville
que j'ai jamais vu une enceinte
colossale d'un blanc calcaire éclatant
entourent la ville à l'intérieur de
nombreux temples émergent au dessus
d'une incroyable prolifération de
maisons de briques marron une armée de
statues gigantesques se dresse tout
autour
le pharaon et sa famille habitent un
palet dans l'enceinte de la ville
l'intérieur peints de couleurs vives
illustrent des scènes de la vie
égyptienne
les plafonds outre repose sur des normes
colonne de pierres
la journée du pharaon débute par le bas
rituel auquel assistent sa suite et des
membres de sa cour
contraint d'apparaître comme un dieu
face à son peuple le roi aura consacre
une grande partie de son temps à soigner
hygiène et apparence
à cette époque et même fils
l'hippopotame est un symbole majeur de
la culture égyptienne sa chasse à
travers les marécages qui bordent le nil
et le sport couramment pratiquées par
les nobles et les pharaons comme le roi
aura
[Musique]
c'est précisément au cours de l'une de
ces chasses que ce dernier trouve la
mort à l'âge de 62 ans
[Applaudissements]
la légende racontée par un prêtre de
l'antiquité veux qu'ils étaient
emportées dans la gueule d'un
hippopotame
[Musique]
mais est-il réellement décédé de cette
manière
il faut se souvenir que l'hippopotame a
une signification religieuse
le mâle personnifie le dieu du mal
dénommé 7
c'est un prêtre qui a permis de
transmettre cette histoire et l'on se
demande s'il n'y a pas derrière elle
d'une manière ou d'une autre l'image du
roi remportée par une incarnation d'une
réelle peut-être que le pharaon est il
mort à 62 ans que de sa belle mort une
mort que les anciens ont préféré
attribués aux dieux cette responsable
également des violente tempête du désert
et dont ils sont habitués à solliciter
la clémence
il est probable qu'on en saura jamais
plus sur la cause réelle de sa
disparition
on pourra toujours partir à la recherche
de quelques indices en visitant sa tombe
située sur l'emplacement d'un ancien
cimetière à l'entrée du désert
le nil la plus grande route fluvial
l'egypte depuis la mort du premier
pharaon aura vers 3010 avant
jésus-christ de rapides embarcations
fait de roseaux à la proue arqués et aux
voiles carrées en toile de lin se sont
mises à circuler sur ces autres c'est
probablement à bord de l'un de ces
bateaux poussé par les vents de la
méditerranée que la dépouille mortelle
doha aura parcouru les quelques 480 km
qui séparent vers le sud
son palais de même fils du lieu saint
david laws
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est avec l'inhumation des premiers
pharaons qu'à dix doses devient
nécropole en hommage au dieu osiris dit
seigneur des morts la renaissance
légendaire de son corps installe la
croyance ou l'egypte antique en une vie
après la mort
[Musique]
douze mètres sous la surface du désert
repose ainsi les restes de l'osi rien
temple david hauss où les égyptiens
anciens venaient rendre leur culte du
dieu de la résurrection
les murs ils sont gravés les chapitres
du livre égyptien des morts manuel
d'instructions l usage des défunts pour
leur passage vers l'au delà
les cadavres enterrés pour la plupart
simplement dans des fosses peu profondes
se flétrissent très rapidement sous
l'effet asséchant du sable
afin de préserver les restes humains
vers l'éternité les pharaons de la
première dynastie décide donc de bâtir
sur ce site de solides tendent
[Musique]
c'est pour eux l'assurance d'une
pérennité aux côtés de laure dieu à
travers laquelle ils pourront continuer
à régner ainsi qu'à maintenir l'ordre de
l'univers
à abidos la tombe réservé aux pharaons
s'appelle une mastaba maury gip siens
pour ben conçu pour traverser l'éternité
la masse tabac est faite de briques de
boue solidifier au soleil surmonté d'un
toit plat incliné sur les côtés à
l'intérieur une série de compartiments
permettent de stocker toute une batterie
d'aliments d'instruments et de meubles
destinés à accompagner en le
réconfortant le roi vers l'éternité
sous ce premier niveau 1 puis descend
vers une pièce souterraine également
faite de briques
c'est là que commence leur peau du
pharaon après que l'on est soigneusement
rebouché l'entrée afin de rendre
l'endroit inaccessible
la plupart des spécialistes estiment que
cette sépulture recensés par les
archéologues sous la référence b19 a
autrefois abrité les restes du pharaon
aura
autour d'elle se trouvent les fosses de
ses fidèles domestique concubine et même
de ces chiens tout sacrifier à sa mort
pour l'accompagner vers l'au delà
[Musique]
une pratique qui finira par être
abandonné l'inhumation auprès du pharaon
va cependant demeurer le privilège des
familles royales et de sujets
prestigieux
[Musique]
à proximité une autre tombe reçoit le
nom de besnéhard qui signifie
littéralement bien aimé il est possible
qu'il s'agisse là du tombeau de la reine
ou éventuellement de la concubine
préférés dora la mort de ce pharaon
marque le début d'une ère de croissance
et de développement pour la civilisation
égyptienne qui durera plus de 800 ans
[Musique]
même fils devient le centre de la vie
culturelle et commerciale du pays
c'est là que s'échangent les animaux
d'élevage et légumes venus de haute
egypte comme l'or l'ivoire et les
pierres précieuses en provenance de
nubie
des statuettes de bois rappelle
certaines scènes de la vie antique
on apprend ainsi que l'orge moulu puis
malaxer sous forme de pâte permet de
produire du pain en très grande quantité
les vaches fournissent la viande le mets
préférés des nobles et puisque un pays
puissant se doit d'avoir une
administration on confie celle ci a une
classe spécifique de la population les
scribes
[Musique]
le rôle des scribes était prépondérante
il représentait la classe officielle
celle des bureaucrates incarnant le
gouvernement et rendant la culture
égyptienne possible si le pharaon était
bien le chef suprême
il lui fallait néanmoins disposer d'une
structure capable de mettre en oeuvre
ces décisions il faut aussi garder
présent à l'esprit que seuls 5 % de la
population savait lire et écrire
concrètement le pharaon délègue la
plupart de ses responsabilités à ses
fonctionnaires appelés vizir
dans la hiérarchie ils font office de
second ces hauts fonctionnaires
égyptiens ont reçu une instruction de
scribe on les représente souvent assis
en tailleur leur papyrus étendu sur les
genoux c'est la position habituelle pour
écrire non seulement le script fait-il
en sorte d'appliquer les désirs de son
souverain mais il est également celui
qui en laisse une trace écrite pour
l'histoire
à la fin de la seconde dynastie en 2007
sans avant jésus-christ en apprend d'une
liste royal ne met la table d'abidos que
pas moins de vingt-deux pharaons ont
régné sur l'egypte depuis corps à a
fondé même fils
seule la signification littérale de
leurs noms nous permet d'en deviner un
peu plus sur ses personnages au tpc
kheloui était le dieu des puissances du
plaisir
cette paire ims un régnait sur les arts
leur masse tabac ont été construites
proche de la capitale de même fils
à
l' architecture de ces édifices fait à
la fois plus imposante est plus complexe
certaines tombes atteignent plus de 5
mètres de hauteur et comporte jusqu'à 70
pièces
[Musique]
la conception sans cesse plus élaboré
des monuments funéraires de ces puissant
pharaon témoigne d'un savoir d'une
richesse et d'une confiance accrue dans
l' architecture
cette tendance à l'esthétisme et à
l'excellence trouvera son point d'orgue
ici à cinq un rat
[Musique]
situé au sud de la ville actuelle du
caire ce remarquable édifice de pierre
n'est autre que le complexe funéraire du
roi jazzer premier pharaon de la
troisième dynastie
sous le règne de djoser qui débute vers
2630 avant jésus-christ le pouvoir du
pharaon est absolu tout le monde du plus
prestigieux des fonctionnaires à
l'esclave le plus anonyme dépend de ses
ordres
joes air dont le nom signifie le plus
sacré est le premier pharaon va explorer
les vastes richesses minières de la
péninsule du sinaï qui s'étend entre les
golfe de suez et d'aqaba
il découvre dans cette région d'immenses
gisements de cuivre de turquoise qui
l'enrichissent encore davantage il
envoie dès lors des émissaires remonter
le nil afin d'étendre son assise jusqu'à
assouan au sud du pays pour proclamer
son prestige absolue il commandite la
toute première pyramides d'égypte une
pyramide à degrés du haut de ses 60 m ce
monument à six niveaux denis un horizon
d'ensemble funéraire au style élaboré
[Musique]
le site funéraire du roi djoser est le
tout premier édifice monumental
entièrement fait de pierres ils nous
offrent surtout de voir à quoi
ressembleront dès lors les nécropoles en
egypte la sépulture décrit clairement un
escalier montant vers les cieux pendant
que réalisations architecturales
elle est un hommage aux mystérieuses
architecte en chef et strip du roi
jazzer imhotep
[Musique]
une inscription de l'époque atteste
d'ailleurs de cet hommage
porteur du sceau du roi d'égypte aussi
proche de sa couronne grand
administrateur de sa suprême résidences
représentant même de sa majesté grand
prêtre d'héliopolis imhotep suis aussi
menuisier sculpteur
pour faire une comparaison plus moderne
on pourrait qualifier imhotep de léonard
de vinci de l'ancienne egypte il était
très doué il représentait absolument
tout il arrivait juste après le roi
comme grand vizir et chef de l'état ils
étaient bardés de au titre mais
curieusement on ne sait pas grand chose
sur lui mis à part son statut on sait
seulement qu'il était le génie
responsable de la grande pyramide la
tombe
kim ho tep réaliste pour le pharaon
djoser reprend en la poussant au
paroxysme la forme traditionnelle de la
masse tabac en assemblant des centaines
de milliers de blocs de calcaire blanc
imhotep empilant réalité si mastaba les
unes sur les autres dont la taille
diminue au fur et à mesure que l'on
monte
le résultat n'est autre qu'un monument
spectaculaire visible à des dizaines de
kilomètres à la ronde
[Musique]
la construction de cette pyramide
coïncide avec le choix de djoser de
faire du dieu solaire ras la divinité
dominante du pays
[Musique]
pour l'honorer ont bâti ainsi l'entrée
des temples attenant à la pyramide
tourner vers l'est au soleil levant
[Musique]
un mur d'enceinte de 9 mètres de haut
truffé de fautes d'entrée et protège le
complexe le site sert de cadre au fait
du obsède un ensemble de cérémonie
célébrant le pharaon comme symboles
magiques de fertilité
[Musique]
celui ci doit suivre un parcours rituel
symbolisant les quatre coins de l'egypte
à l'intérieur de l'une des galeries de
la pyramide un relief représente jaws
air dans sa frénésie d'un parcours
rythmé par les incantations de sa cour
[Musique]
dieu du destin qui nous offrent les
récoltes les plus abondantes piliers du
ciel et soutien de la terre leaders des
deux rives du nil
partout sur les traces de ses sandales
pousse la plus riche des moissons
[Musique]
la fête du obsède avait lieu à peu près
tous les trente ans du règne du même
pharaon
c'était une manière très civilisée de
faire reverdir la vie en remettant
l'accent sur la prospérité de l'egypte
si dans d'autres cultures on préférait
tuer le roi pour le remplacer par un
plus jeune
les égyptiens eux célébraient
tranquillement leur rituel toujours à
côté de leurs droits
[Musique]
jazz air ne règne que 19 ans
suffisamment pour qu'à sa mort en 2006
sans 49 avant jésus-christ il laisse à
l'égypte ancienne une tradition de
construction des pyramides qui se
perpétuera en même temps qu'elle
s'enrichit pendant deux millénaires
[Musique]
les écrivains anciens qui nous ont
transmis l'histoire de l'egypte nous
apprennent que cette troisième dynastie
resté célèbre pour la toute première
pyramide de jaws r c'est un en 2006 113
avant jésus-christ
[Musique]
le dernier de ces pharaons uni n'a
laissé aucun fils héritier du trône
lui succède pour 24 ans de règne snif
frau dans la liste royal david hauss
nous enseigne qu'il est également
originaire de memphis mais d'une lignée
différente
[Musique]
son mariage avec la soeur du pharaon uni
étape
erès marque le début de la ivème
dynastie en même temps qu'il unit deux
filiation différentes
[Musique]
une dynastie qui durera plus de 400 ans
partagé entre 17 pharaons différents
[Musique]
le nom de ce n'est frousse et y fit
porter de beauté alors que son
prédécesseur jose air s'est attaché à
repousser les frontières de l'egypte
jusqu'à assouan au sud du pays
le nouveau pharaon cherche à étendre
encore son influence
pour ce faire il mène une campagne
lointaine sur les terres de nubie et
s'installe dans la citadelle de bus n
le lieu lui servira de base pour ses
expéditions minière son commerce et
autres conquêtes
on rapporte qu il serait rentré
accompagné de 7000 captifs nubien
probablement destinés aux travaux
agricoles ainsi que de quelques deux
cent mille têtes de bétail
certaines peintures illustre des animaux
exotiques comme des girafes des babouins
rapporté du continent africain est remis
en offrande au premier roi pour leur
plus grande joie
tout porte à croire qu'à l'instar de son
prédécesseur snefc roues et chercher à
exploiter les richesses minières du
golfe de suez
cette sculpture célèbre une incursion
dans les mines de turquoise de la
péninsule du sinaï où l'on voit ce n'est
frau tuer un ennemi
l'inscription décrit le pharaon comme un
grand dieu lancer à la conquête des
terres étrangères
[Musique]
le bois d'oeuvre et de charpente est une
autre de ces matières premières très
recherchés on en a besoin en quantité
afin de construire les mam et les
poutres des résidences bourgeoise mais
ce bois manque en egypte et il faut
aller se le procurer par delà les mers
[Musique]
forts de leur expérience de navigateurs
sur le nil les égyptiens deviennent les
premiers meilleurs marins de l'antiquité
c'est sous le règne de ce n'est frau
qu'il s'embarque pour la première fois
la recherche de bois de cèdre le pharaon
ordonne la construction de 60 navires
marchands
bientôt des flottes de gracieux voilier
font route vers l'ancienne byblos
aujourd'hui jedi au liban l'un des
strips de sefrou parle même de 40
navires remplis de rondins de cèdre des
inscriptions murales de l'époque nous
enseigne aussi que ceux des frous placée
haut fonctionnaire dans des propriétés
fait de bric et de rondins de cèdre il
reste cependant attentif à ce qu'elles
soient suffisamment espacées les unes
des autres afin que ces sujets ne soient
pas tentés de se regrouper pour fonder
leur propre royaume au sud du pays
ce qui ne les empêche pas pour autant de
faire la fête quand bon lui semble
[Musique]
aux dires de tous
la vie s'écoule paisiblement sous le
règne de ce n'est frau
[Musique]
au troisième millénaire avant
jésus-christ l'egypte est un pays de
paix et d'abondance le nouveau pharaon
et sa reine invite de manière
protocolaire les nobles les membres de
la cour y festoient également se
régalant de canard du accompagné de
figues ses habitants de la vieille
memphis sont des esthètes soucieux de
leur apparence
ils portent perruque robe de cérémonie
en lin et se maquillent le tour des yeux
[Musique]
les égyptiens anciens attache également
beaucoup d'importance au parfum destiné
à masquer les odeurs corporelles signe
de pêcher c'est ainsi que les femmes de
l'élite porte sur la tête des cônes de
graisse parfumé qui finissent par fondre
à la chaleur de ces longues soirées pour
se répandre le long de leur corps
[Musique]
un autre papyrus relate comment le roi
ce n'est frousse ennuyant travers ce sol
un lac à la rame pour rejoindre une
magnifique jeune femme drapée d'un
simple filet de pêche
[Musique]
enfin les égyptiens anciens restent très
attachés à leur passé qu'incarne par
définition l'esprit des défunts ceci
explique pourquoi l'ultime demeurent des
morts la pyramide reste le symbole
persistant de toute la culture
égyptienne
le phare ans mais frau choisi lui aussi
de déplacer la nécropole royale
mais cette fois sur le site de dahchour
au bord du nil
c'est là qu'il fait bâtir les premières
véritables pyramide
au cours du 20e siècle l'endroit reste
la plupart du temps interdit au public
seule une poignée d'archéologues est
autorisé à y pénétrer
ouvert depuis peu aux visiteurs ce site
offre un aperçu exceptionnel des
constructions commandité par snefc roues
et qui domine l'horizon désertique
presque lunaire de cette région
s'élevant à 104 mètres au dessus du
sable voici la pyramide courbet la toute
première réalisation de ce n'est frau
qu'il surnomme la brillante pyramide du
sud
sa forme particulière a conduit certains
spécialistes à penser que le pharaon
était décédé brutalement et qu'il a
fallu terminer les travaux à la hâte
en réalité cette silhouette étrange nous
en apprend beaucoup sur la technique
employée par les bâtisseurs de ceux des
fronts
ce type de pyramide est certainement ce
qu'on appelle un des premiers grands
demi-citron de l'histoire lorsqu'ils ont
commencé les travaux
les architectes égyptiens n'ont pas
réalisé tout de suite que le sol ne
supporterait pas le poids d'un tel
monument
ils ne s'en sont aperçus qu'à mi chemin
lorsque des fissures on sait que toutes
sortes de problèmes de structure sont
apparus il aura fallu modifier la courbe
et la rendre moins pentues de sorte que
l'on puisse aller j'ai d'urgence la
masse de l'édifice
à l'intérieur ce n'est frau fait placer
sur le mur d'une chambre ce relief de
calcaire le représentant vêtu de la
tenue du renouveau ou fait du obsède
la double couronne confiant que l'on se
trouve en présence du souverain des
hautes et basses egypte
à l'extérieur il supervise la
construction d'une annexe rue paul
complexe dont subsiste encore une partie
[Musique]
les pharaons garder un oeil très
attentif sur leurs monuments en
particulier funéraire comme les
pyramides et lé temple mortuaire
il se déplaçait sans doute très souvent
sur les chantiers pour contrôler
l'avancement des travaux
et peu importe en définitive la
puissance du pharaon au cours de son
règne
sa prospérité éternelle dépendent est
entièrement de la qualité de sa tombe
à titre personnel ces chantiers
constituaient donc l'un des événements
majeurs de leur règne et malheur à
l'architecte en chef
si le projet tourné mal ce qui arrive
est quelquefois
[Musique]
tel est le destin de la pyramide courbet
de ce n'est frau ces salles resteront à
jamais vide
ces architectes ne seront pas pour
autant puni à presque deux kilomètres au
nord et réalise un véritable
chef-d'oeuvre l'édifice le plus
saisissant qu'il soit donné de voir à
dachau la pyramide rose
culminant à 105 m c'est la toute
première pyramide régulière construite
au monde
elle tient son nom de la roche à partir
de laquelle on l'a bâti riche en oxyde
de fer lapierre prend en effet une
tournure rougeâtre sous le soleil du
désert
[Musique]
la réalisation par ces fous de cette
pyramide rouge suit de peu l'émergence
de rats dieu solaire comme divinité
dominante du pays
elle matérialise par la pierre le
passage du soleil ses arêtes
reproduisent en effet l'inclinaison des
rayons frappant la terre à travers les
éclaircies du ciel
[Musique]
est aussi une manière de dire la place
divine qu'occupe le pharaon dans la
société égyptienne
le roi se situait au sommet de la
pyramide c'est le pharaon il rayonnait
d'abord vers sa famille immédiate qu'ils
occupaient symboliquement les couches
supérieures puis progressivement vers la
base la plus large de l'édifice
ceci nous éclaire sur l'unité du royaume
et sur le degré d'implication qui
régnait les gens étaient heureux de
répondre à l'appel du pharaon et de
s'investir dans la construction d'un
monument dédié à sa conversion en dieu
après sa mort c'était pour eux en retour
l'assurance de leur bien-être sur terre
l'ironie du sort veut que lapointe tous
impôts de la pyramide rouge symbolisant
donc ce n'est faux soit tombé au sol où
elle est restée depuis
[Musique]
hao des grands prêtres de ce n'est frou
et nos frais de sa femme repose dans une
masse tabac au sud de la pyramide des
statuts de calcaire pain lait
représentent les égyptiens pensent que
le réalisme de leurs sculptures aidera
les esprits à reconnaître leur demeure
depuis l'au delà
[Musique]
les traits caractéristiques de ces
oeuvres nous offre un regard tout à fait
exceptionnelle sur l'apparence physique
de ces égyptiens anciens
de manière anecdotique les premiers
explorateurs sont tellement saisi par la
véracité de leurs yeux de verre qu'ils
laissent tomber leurs outils et s'enfuit
[Musique]
leurs regards sont comme figé vers
l'éternité la solennité de leur
expression est censée montrer leur
confiance dans l'immortalité de par la
relation directe qui les lie aux
pharaons
la femme ne ferais tu as le statut de
princesse à au tep en plus de son titre
de grand prêtre se voit décrit par sa
statue comme fils du roi de son état une
inscription qui a conduit certains
spécialistes à s'avancer sur le lien
fort possible de filiation avec le phare
ans les fronts
snif frau lui même se destine à reposer
au sein de son chef-d'oeuvre sa pyramide
rose
à l'intérieur un magnifique couloir
s'ouvre sur une chambre funéraire dont
le plafond à près de 14 mètres de
hauteur repose sur des poutres de bois
pillé depuis bien longtemps cette
chambre renfermait outre le corps de son
royal occupants d'inimaginable richesse
et
on pense à l'époque que le pharaon suit
à travers le puits de lumière
l'alternance des jours et des nuits
mais depuis leur tombe de pierre les
cadavres se décomposent rapidement sous
l'effet de la moisissure
les égyptiens anciens réalise ainsi
qu'ils ne font que détruire ce qu'ils
espéraient préserver et à la mort de ce
n'est frau préfère considérer qu'il est
devenu autre chose
[Musique]
surgie des sables tel d'énormes monstres
dominant un paysage désertique
les pyramides de gizeh figurent parmi
les monuments les plus imposants de
toute l'histoire de l'humanité
en même temps qu'elles reflètent les
aspirations de leurs trois
commanditaires
elles demeurent lé témoignage
remarquable d'une période de l'egypte
antique où l'expérience secret des
bâtisseurs de pyramides est à son apogée
[Musique]
c'est sous la ivème dynastie que le
pharaon entreprennent les projets de
construction les plus ambitieux qui est
été
[Musique]
cheops qui a succédé à son père snefc
rouen 2551 avant jésus-christ ouvre la
marche
[Musique]
après la pyramide courbet et la pyramide
rouge de dahchour lui s'attelle à plus
colossal encore sur le plateau de guizeh
[Musique]
cheops bâtisseurs de la grande pyramide
a la particularité d'avoir hérité d'un
royaume à la fois puissants centralisée
est très stable et bien que cette grande
pyramide nous impressionne il ne faut
pas oublier que son père avait
l'expérience de deux pyramides qui
d'ailleurs si on les réunit c'est il
dépasserait de loin la taille de la
grande pyramide de khéops ne fait donc
que perpétuer une tradition qui existait
déjà avant lui
avec ses 146 mètres de haut la pyramide
de khéops dépasse la statue américaine
de la liberté la cathédrale saint-pierre
de rome ou même une fusée apollo sur sa
rampe de lancement
elle reste en fait la plus grande
structure jamais élevé jusqu'à ce que la
tour eiffel lui dament le pion à partir
de 1889
le but étant simplement qu'on puisse la
voir de partout le fait qu'ils aient
choisi un plateau est très important qui
plus est un plateau situé sur un relief
déjà élevé on apercevait son monument
depuis tout le nord du pays les quatre
points de la capitale
vous pouvez aussi suivre l'avancée des
travaux
[Musique]
on édifie cette grande pyramide à partir
de blocs de pierre pesant chacun en
moyenne de tonnes de plus de 2 millions
300 mille de ces blocs viennent ainsi
s'imbriquer dans un ordre si parfait
qu'il est difficile de ne pas penser un
seul instant un projet d'ordre divin
[Musique]
à l'intérieur proche du sommet une salle
de granit rouge appelée grande galerie
sert de dernière demeure au pharaon
tout au bout de cette pièce se trouve le
sarcophage de granit rouge du pharaon
khéops
[Musique]
le terme de sarcophages le vient des
mots grecs sarc la chaire eiffage manger
c'est cercueil de pierre sont en
d'autres termes perçus comme des boîtes
à manger la chair
comment les égyptiens sont ils parvenus
à extraire tailler et déplacé une telle
quantité de pierres vers le plateau de
gizeh depuis des siècles la question
continue de défier les spécialistes il
n'y a à cette époque ni bête de somme ni
deux roues suffisamment solides pour
tracter soulevé autant de poids aussi
grâce à cette réalisation
cheops devient-il symbole de puissance
absolue
hérodote historien grec du vème siècle
fait la chronique de l'extrême cruauté
du pharaon khéops les a poussés aux
confins de la misère
mais avant cela il a pris soin de les
extirper des temples pour éviter qu'ils
ne s'y sacrifie puis il a ordonné à tous
les égyptiens de travailler à son projet
certains étaient chargés de pousser les
blocs de pierre depuis leurs carrières
des montagnes l'arabe jusqu'en il
le peuple travaillé par immense groupe
de cent mille personnes et par période
de trois mois
il a fallu 20 ans pour bâtir la pyramide
la malfaisance de khéops était telle que
lorsqu'il avait besoin d'argent il
envoyait sa propre fille se prostituer
dans une maison close
[Musique]
les spécialistes actuels restent
cependant sceptiques sur la réelle
barbarie du roi khéops l'idée selon
laquelle kheops était un souverain
inhumain semble trouver son origine dans
un texte daté d'une période bien plus
tardive et dans lequel on le décrit en
réalité plus comme un souverain qui
s'ennuie ou d'un tempérament indifférent
que comme quelqu'un de véritablement
cruel les historiens y ont repris plus
tard cette idée pour nous en parler
cette fois d'un tyran mais nous n'avons
en vérité aucune preuve
on dispose en effet de très peu d'écrits
sur le commanditaire de la grande
pyramide
mis à part à bust de granit censés le
représenter
seule une statuette d'ivoire à son
effigie a traversé les millénaires
jusqu'à nous
[Musique]
proche de sa pyramide acquise est un
champ de sépulture récemment mise à jour
laissent à penser que les restes exhumés
sont ceux des ouvriers dont le travail
éreintant a permis l'édification de la
grande pyramide
ces travailleurs rue style été à
proprement parler des esclaves cheops ne
leur aurais certainement pas fait
l'honneur de les enterrer si près de lui
[Musique]
on sait en revanche qu'au début de la
ivème dynastie
non seulement la construction des
pyramides est parvenu à un niveau
technique très élevé mais aussi que la
pratique de l'embaumement a évolué vers
and arts mystiques et ésotérique
consistant à métamorphoser les cadavres
en meunerie l'initier à peu de choses
près sous le règne de ce n'est frau la
technique de la momification devient une
étape essentielle dans la religion
égyptienne
il s'agit en effet de faire passer le
phare amendé fin de son état de
souverains terrestre à celui de roi
céleste
[Musique]
on pense alors qu'en parvenant à
conserver le corps du pharaon
on garde son esprit intacte pour
l'éternité un minutieux rituel
d'embaumement vise à préserver le
cadavre de sa décomposition ainsi qu'à
lui rendre ses facultés afin qu'ils
puissent profiter de l'aménagement de sa
tombe
cette momification nous offre la
possibilité quelques 4000 ans plus tard
le découvrir les visages de ces pharaons
et d'autres de leurs contemporains
elle reste avant tout l'occasion de
mesurer le caractère terrestre du marbre
clamé me roy mi dieu
les analyses effectuées sur ces mamies
nous révèle que les pharaons souffrait
de calculs biliaires de tuberculose de
polio d'appendicite deux hernies de pied
bot et de choléra
tout près de la pyramide de khéops ont
été découverts des puits rempli de
mystérieux morceaux de bois de cèdre du
liban
[Musique]
en parvenant à rassembler les fragments
les archéologues découvrent un bateau de
43 mètres de long ayant probablement
appartenu au successeur de khéops en
2005 128 avant jésus-christ
celui ci n'est autre que son fils j'ai
des frais dans le nom signifiant rayon
de lumière persistant renvoie encore au
fameux dieu solaire
[Musique]
premier pharaon a adopté ouvertement
cette référence
j'ai des frais présidera lui-même aux
funérailles de son père
à gizeh
le pharaon jefferies gouverne dix ans
avant que son frère kephren ne lui
succède en 2005 120 avant jésus-christ
kephren dont la signification littérale
d'apparition semblables à celles de rat
affirme davantage encore la référence au
dieu solaire débute immédiatement la
construction d'une seconde pyramide sur
le plateau de guizeh tout laisse penser
que les travaux de celle ci érigée à sa
propre gloire et à l'ombre du maniement
de son père se sont étalés sur les
trente années de son règne du semble que
sous le règne de khephren des égyptiens
étaient également très prospère pourtant
certains ont avancé que le début de
l'épuisement des ressources ainsi que la
concentration de la population investi
dans ces grands travaux étaient telles
que la pauvreté a commencé à s'installer
à peu près à cette époque en egypte 1
l'accession de khephren au pouvoir marc
certainement un tournant dans l'histoire
de la ivème dynastie débuter quelque six
cents ans plus tôt
le pharaon participent à
l'enrichissement de la culture
égyptienne en faisant bâtir un temple
mortuaire au style raffiné orné d'une
splendide statue de lui même grandeur
nature et que protège le dieu faucon aux
russes
mais le symbole le plus éminent du règne
de khephren reste sans doute le
majestueux grand sphinx qui se dresse à
l'est du plateau de gizeh à l'ombre de
sa pyramide
[Musique]
les égyptiens vous une véritable
vénération à cet animal mystique gardien
des lieux sacrés il y a ainsi plus de
4500 ans les ouvriers de khephren
sculpte un énorme lions de pierre auquel
il donne le visage de leurs droits c'est
le plus ancien portrait royal de cette
taille que l'on connaisse
pourvu d'oreilles de plus de trois
mètres cinquante de haut dieu atteignant
presque deux mètres d'un corps de 73 m
les trois quarts d'un terrain de
football et d'une tête culminant à plus
de 20 mètres l'équivalent d'un immeuble
de six étages
le sphinx qui signifie étrangleur tient
son nom des grecs qu'il entend ainsi
baptisé après être tombé à l'improviste
sur cette fabuleuse créatures de pierre
[Musique]
on est là dans une zone de carrière il
est probable que le sphinx et été
sculptée à partir du soubassement laissé
par l'extraction de la pierre destinés à
la construction de la pyramide les
spécialistes nous apprennent que le
grand sphinx a plus vraisemblablement
été sculptée à partir de l'excédent de
pierres extraites pour la pyramide de
khéphren sa raison d'être demeure
cependant inconnu sol dans le silence du
désert
accroupies face à son complexe de
pyramides et le sphinx et son long
regard de pierre nous défient en
permanence sans jamais nous apporter de
réponse claire
pour tout indice
il nous reste ce visage et rodez usé par
les intempéries et la marque du temps
fixant par delà la plaine le soleil
couchant
l'histoire à son tour nous dira qu'un
jour ce même soleil s'est couché une
toute dernière fois sur la fantastique
dynastie des pharaons de guizeh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]